MARK: Well, welcome
everyone to Talks at Google.
We have a very
special guest today,
which is Dr. Susan Murphy.
Susan is a professor of
statistics and psychiatry
at the University of Michigan.
She's been doing
research on developing
wearable mobile devices in
the health care industry.
She's also received some
amazing awards, including
a Fellow-- this one, actually,
is pretty impressive--
the Fellowship as a
MacArthur Fellow in 2013,
and received over $600,000 no
strings attached [INAUDIBLE]
to do research, because she's
shown exceptional creativity
and promised to do more.
She's working on projects that
are helping a lot of people,
which we'll hear about today.
So thanks for joining us.
I'll turn the time
over to Susan.
SUSAN MURPHY: Thanks, Mark.
OK.
It's a pleasure to be
here with all of you.
So you can see from
this first slide
that this is about
mobile health,
and I've been really fortunate.
I'm part of multiple groups
that work in mobile health.
So here I have my
little pictures,
one on physical activity.
We also have some work in
smoking cessation, right now
in alcoholism, drug abuse,
also congestive heart failure
as well.
And that involves most of
these different groups.
And today we're going to
spend most of our time
when I talk about
an example, I'll
talk about the physical
activity study.
So what I'm going to do here is
even as a quantitative person,
it's really important
to be careful about what
are all the parts of
a project or an entity
that you're building.
In this case, it's a
mobile health intervention.
And you have to think,
what are all the parts,
so that you can
think of each part
and then how to
optimize that part.
And so that's what I'm
going to go through first.
So it's going to
all be very verbal,
but I'm talking--
because one needs
to think about each one of
these parts to optimize them.
So this is adaptive
interventions.
Adaptive interventions--
that's a name of a design
that mobile health interventions
fit within that name.
And the idea is these
are interventions,
where you want to tailor the
intervention to the person.
One thinks that there may be
systematic reasons why people
respond differently,
and to the extent
that you can use those
systematic reasons
to personalize treatment,
you'd like to do that.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you an older
example, and the reason
why I'm showing this to you
is-- it's very simple.
It doesn't involve
mobile health,
but it helps really
communicate the ideas.
And it's, for me,
very interesting is
that we in the mobile
health field, we forget--
in the health field in general--
we forget that a lot of what we
do has a lot of relevance
for social problems
and social programs.
And this really gets at that.
So this is an adapted
drug court program
for drug abusing offenders.
So what happens is
you get arrested,
and you're offered
the opportunity
to bypass jail and go
into a drug court program,
and that's what we're
talking about individuals
who had that opportunity.
And what happens is these
individuals come in,
and this is a study that
went on in Philly, actually.
And I was a consultant
on this study,
and they wanted to develop an
adaptive intervention, which
they called the Adaptive
Drug Court Program.
This is a big coup
actually, because this
is working with the judicial
system, which is nontrivial.
AUDIENCE: Are we able to
ask questions [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN MURPHY: I think
it would be nice.
Is that OK?
MARK: Sure.
SUSAN MURPHY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In a
program like this,
Mark had talked about your
research receiving funds.
Is this funded by
a grant, or is this
funded by a university that's
thinking this is interesting?
Is it funded by the
judicial system?
SUSAN MURPHY: Yeah.
Right.
This is a good question.
So he asked me, how do these
types of projects get funded?
And in the world I live
in, for the most part,
we're always interested
in edgy kind of projects.
So they tend to be funded
by NIH or foundations
like the Ford Foundation
or some other foundation.
Autism Speaks has funded some
of our work, for example.
You also see work funded
by industry as well.
Every now and then,
little bitty bits
will get funded
by the university,
but that's not really
where the money is.
AUDIENCE: So it alleviates then
the court systems or taxpayers
were paying for some of these.
SUSAN MURPHY: Oh yeah.
The taxpayers-- they were
paying for it, but not
through the judicial system.
It was via a
research project that
was funded by the National
Institutes of Health.
So the whole goal
was to figure out,
can we produce a good program?
So people were
classifying-- what you
see is a decision tree here.
And you can think of most
adaptive interventions as akin
to decision trees.
People were classified
into low risk or high risk.
This is a diagnosis of
antisocial personality disorder
or formal drug abuse treatment.
They're brought in.
They're provided standard
group-based drug abuse
counseling, and they're
provided two different options
of a very expensive
intervention,
judicial supervision.
So that's where the game
is here, the expense
of judicial supervision.
Can you reduce that?
And can you only step
it up if you need to?
Every month they're monitored,
and at the end of each month,
they could be doing well.
Everything's fine.
Or they might be non-compliant.
That means they're not following
the rules of the drug court
program.
They're not showing up to
enough drug abuse sessions--
two or more-- or they're
not providing urine screens
every week.
If they're non-compliant,
the judicial supervision
is stepped up at the
end of that month.
If they're doing
well, nothing happens.
They just stay in
the same thing.
If they're
non-responsive, that's
someone who's
really trying hard,
but they're providing positive
urine screens-- more than two.
And then you don't want to
up the judicial supervision.
Instead, you want to increase
the support for drug abuse
therapy.
And so they move to what's
called intensive case
management.
This includes
individual-based therapy
and a lot of different
supportive services.
The whole goal of
this project was
to help people graduate
from the drug program, as
opposed to going back
into jail, which is
a very expensive intervention.
So this is an
adaptive intervention,
and it has these
elements that one really
needs to think about when
you think about forming
one of these interventions.
So there's always some
sort of distal outcome.
In this case, it was
helping people graduate
from the drug abuse program.
You can imagine
in other settings,
that distal outcome might
be a tradeoff between cost
and benefit.
There's always a
proximal response here.
In our case, the proximal
response was whether or not
you were compliant each
month, or you were responsive,
whether or not you
have positive urines.
So that's what we're
looking-- we're
looking to see how you're
responding, compliance.
You're responsive.
And then the decision
tree is formed
by what people in this field
call tailoring variables.
Those are the variables
we use to make decisions.
In our case, they
are, in fact, the same
as the proximal response.
The decision rules, which
is that little decision
tree, kinds of treatments
we have-- We're ready.
We're able to provide levels
of judicial supervision, levels
of drug abuse therapy.
And then you trigger--
you have to think
about when you're going to
trigger the decision rules.
And in a drug abuse
program, it was monthly,
so at very coarse
intervals in time.
And all of this has to be
thought carefully about if you
want to get something that's
both cost-effective and
effective.
So let's go to a more
of a mobile setting.
So here, people call these just
in time adaptive interventions
to communicate the
fact that you're
trying to intervene at the
time, in the moment, where
a person really can use help
at 2:00 AM in the stairwell,
delivered when needed,
wherever needed.
So here's a really simple
example that I like.
It's highly simplistic.
Nowadays things have gotten
much more sophisticated,
and this is where you
have software that's
monitoring your mouse activity,
as well as your keyboard
activity on the computer.
You're an office worker.
And if you go 30 minutes
with uninterrupted activity,
you get a ping, and it suggests
that you stand up and walk
around the room.
Actually, there's a variety of
different kinds of messages,
and they had the messages
compete with each other
to see which one would be
best for you in what setting.
So we're going to be talking
about this in the mobile health
setting.
This is not mobile,
but it is just in time.
It has that connotation.
So what's common about
adaptive interventions
and these just in time
is they're time
varying treatments.
You see treatments
changing over time.
The idea is you're going
to adapt the treatment
to the individual.
You're going to personalize
treatment in some way.
However, in our just
in time intervention,
it's technology-based.
It's really focused,
and, indeed, often,
you'd want access to wearable
sensor streams and so on.
You want to be able
to collect information
wherever it's needed so that you
get the right kind of tailoring
variable, so you
know what to do.
You know you can identify
moments of opportunity,
moments of risk.
And you want to be able
to deliver interventions
in the real life of the person.
So it's the exact
same game as before.
The components are
the exact same.
There's nothing
spectacularly new here.
It's just that everything
becomes more in the moment.
At first, I used
to say momentary,
but I don't want to
give you the impression
that the effects
might be fleeting.
But they're in
the moment, so I'm
trying to help you with
your craving right now.
I'm trying to help you
be active right now.
And the decision
points are real time.
And what I'm going to do on
the next couple of slides
is I'm going to go
through each one of these,
and it turns out
right now, the state
of the field in mobile
health-- it's pretty immature.
And this makes it really
exciting for scientists
and technology developers,
because most of this,
we don't have good--
we don't really
know how to optimize yet.
We know that we got problems.
We know where we need to go, but
we haven't gotten it straight
in our head how to optimize it.
So we're going to start
off by the distal outcome.
So the distal outcome
is some long term goal
that you want to achieve.
And in the world
I live in, which
is more on the research,
more research side,
it usually is some sort
of clinical outcome
like I'm trying
to delay the time
to relapse in substance use.
I'm trying to reduce the rate
at which people binge eat.
I'm trying to keep people
from drinking heavily,
binge drinking, and so on.
And a lot of areas maintain
adherence to medications.
It's very common.
The whole idea here is you
formulate your intervention
options, the interventions
that you might provide
so that you'll affect
these proximal responses,
and thus achieve
your distal outcome.
So in the behavioral
science world,
this fits in very well
with the way the theories
with which they
guide their thinking.
So proximal responses--
they're often called mediators.
I don't know if
you all would have
heard those words, mediators.
They're used a lot in
the behavioral sciences,
and if you think of A causes
B, and then B causes C,
B is the mediator.
A doesn't cause C directly.
It causes B, and
then B causes C.
So there's this causal chain
that you want to impact.
So here, I've
given some examples
of what the proximal
response might
be-- substance use
over the near time,
if you're interested in reducing
relapse, a physical activity,
if you're trying to help people
who want to be less obese,
medication adherence
over the next time.
So this is the same as the
short term targeted behavior.
The distal outcome
is a behavior.
The proximal response
In other settings, it's some
measure of short-term risk.
So for example, in
smoking cessation,
one of the big determinants
of why people tend to relapse
is having problems
with stress management,
because smoking is used
to help you manage stress.
And so stress would be a
classical kind of mediator
that you might want to impact.
And the last one--
this is something
that we end up in the
mobile health field,
we're really starting to realize
how absolutely critical it is.
And I think someone
in business would've
realized this maybe even
earlier-- is engagement.
So if you're dealing
with a problem, which
is chronic like, for
example, substance use,
being physically active, eating
well, managing your stress,
this is something
you have to deal
with for long periods of time.
If we don't keep
you engaged, when
things start to go
downhill, that app
will not be there for you.
So engagement could be another
type of proximal response.
The kinds of intervention
options-- this,
too, is very-- it's
quite interesting.
I didn't realize
there were so many,
but it's a vast array of
different kinds of ways
that we can try and
help people, ways
to reframe a relapse,
alternative activities
to help me deal with
craving for a cigarette.
Maybe there's different
interventions,
little interventions
that are on the phone,
residing on my
smartphone, yet I don't
I think when I
should access them,
because I'm not so self-aware.
I'm so stressed out.
I'm not that aware right now.
So it might be a nudge
to access an intervention
that I can obtain on the phone.
Self-monitoring-- prompt me
to record my diet or something
at that time.
And of course, there's the
provide nothing option, which
actually is one of the
best options of all,
because I don't know how you
all are, but my smartphone
and me-- we stay
together all the time.
When I take a shower, my
smartphone is on the sink.
When I go to bed, my
smartphone is next-- I mean, me
and my smartphone-- we're
together all the time.
And so the issue of
burden and aggravation
is profound in this domain.
It's much more profound than
in any other area of health
I know of in terms of just
aggravation to the person.
So the provide nothing option
is, of course, a good one.
So tailoring variables--
these are the variables
you use to decide whether or not
to provide a push or support.
Often, they are
proximal responses
you've already observed.
Whether or not you're
going into a risky period,
like if I want to suggest that
you might go and go for a walk
or somehow break your
sedentary behavior,
I might want to look at
the busyness of your Google
Calendar over the
next couple hours,
because it might not be worth
it to suggest you go for
walk if you're going
straight into a whole series
of meetings, and so on.
And of course,
adherence, too, might
be if you're showing signs that
you're becoming more aggravated
with the intervention.
Maybe I need to back off.
The phone should back off.
The algorithm should
back off [INAUDIBLE].
So these all could be
tailoring variables.
Decision points--
these are the time
points at which you have
to decide whether or not
you might intervene.
So this is complicated,
and it's something
that we really don't have
quite straight in the science,
because it's tailored to the
dynamics of whatever process
you're trying to impact.
So with stress, for
example, we don't really
understand how volatile
stress might be for people
who are trying to quit smoking.
How volatile is it in a
dynamic way over the day?
So how often might we want
to intervene during the day?
That's not very clear.
In the smoking
cessation study, we
decided-- I'm not going to
talk about that study here,
but we have decision
points at every minute,
because we don't know
yet how volatile it is,
so we picked the smallest
time at which we could
get classifications of stress.
Also, the intervention
may only have
an impact over a short period
of time, and that'll inform.
The decision
rules-- so these can
be decision rules
like a decision tree
like I showed you
before, except in more
of a real-time kind of setting.
They can be if/then
kind of rules.
In some settings, they're
black box type rules
that it's an output
of an algorithm.
If you go to the
behavioral sciences,
and you go to the
research field,
most people hand tailor,
hand tune the decision rules.
There's some indirect use of
data, but for the large part,
people hand tune it.
And so what this talk from
now on is going to be about
is how we might
collect data so that we
could use data to inform that
tuning of these decision rules.
Oh, here's just an
example in the case
of the sedentary computer
behavior of a decision
rule in the if/then framework,
as opposed to a decision tree.
Just thought I'd
give you an example.
So here's my tailoring variable.
Here's an intervention option.
We have a threshold on
the tailoring variable.
We might want to learn with data
what the best threshold might
be, and that
threshold might vary
by person, because my
tolerance of being pinged
might be lower than
someone else's,
so you might have to have
a higher threshold for me
than someone else.
Or in this particular setting,
whatever's going on today
may mean my threshold for
being pinged is lower.
So here's the summary.
I'm just going to
skip this, but it's
a summary of the way behavioral
scientists might think
about when they
think about forming
one of these interventions.
So I want to go
on to Heart Steps.
Heart Steps is a study
that just-- well, actually,
it says set.
This is one of
these studies that's
funded by the National
Institutes of Health,
and it's a study that involves
three different trials.
In the first trial,
the last two trials
would be with individuals
who had a heart attack,
and we're trying to
help them stay active
after the heart
attack to prevent
future cardiovascular problems.
The first study's just
for sedentary people,
because we're trying--
if you've ever
worked a lot with
technology, there's
really a lot of bugs you've got
to deal with in this setting.
So that's Heart
Steps, and that's
what we're going
to talk about next.
So Heart Steps--
what it involves
is in the first of the three
studies we used as a Jawbone
on the wrist to get step count
as well as sleep quality.
And we built a little
app on the phone,
and of course, this app has
a lot of supportive stuff
that is involved in
that app, but I'm
going to focus on
only certain aspects.
So the distal outcome--
it was a 42-day study,
and in this particular
case, we were
looking to increase the
sedentary individuals'
activity over the
duration of the 42 days.
But however, the way we
wanted to do this is we
wanted to provide them
actionable suggestions
that when I say
actionable, this means
you need to know what context
they're in at that moment.
Actionable
suggestions they could
use to be less sedentary
in that moment.
And so the proximal
response is going
to be some measure--
in this case, step
count-- of their activity
following a decision point.
And at a decision
point, we could give
different kinds of messages.
In fact, here, it turns
out we had three options.
We wouldn't bother you at
all at a decision point,
or we would give you one of
two varieties of an activity
recommendation.
One is an activity
recommendation
that's just aimed at
reducing sedentary behavior.
For example, I got one in the
office one day in the mid day,
and it suggested I stand
up and roll my arms.
It was actually very actionable.
I liked it.
But others are about going for
a walk like a 10-minute walk,
so it's much more
onerous for me.
I mean, I really need to
be in the right setting
to be able to act on that.
The decision times were every
two to two and a half hours,
and you might ask why.
And in fact, we
spent a lot of time
trying to get that
straight in our head.
We were lucky this is
part of a big team,
and a group of us on
this team had access
to large amounts
of Jawbone data.
And they looked to see when was
the most variance in activity
in people's lives.
So if there's a lot of
variance at that time,
there's the potential to
increase their activity,
because there is times at which
they would be active sometimes
at those times.
And it turned out these
were five times a day
right before you went to
work, pre-morning commute,
around midday, mid-afternoon,
around when you're leaving
work, and in the evening.
And that's about every two
to two and a half hours,
so five times a day.
So originally, we were going
to do it much more frequently,
but once we looked at the
date, it was very clear,
this is when you saw that
variance, this potential
to have impact.
So how might a
recommendation look?
And I'm going to focus on no
message versus a message here.
And I got this message-- I
think this was last year.
It was absolutely frigid.
It was wonderful, actually.
It was a beautiful day.
It was sunny.
March 14-- it was on
a Saturday, so it's
going to only give
me a message, which
makes sense on a Saturday.
It won't give me a message
about work, for example,
because I'm not at work.
And actually, it was in
the middle of the day.
So here it suggested that I
try and make a warm treat,
and maybe do some jumping
jacks, move around a lot
while I was at work.
These suggestions are
tailored to the day
of the week, the time of the
day, the weather outside.
For example, if it's absolutely
nasty weather outside,
we're not going to suggest
that you go for a walk outside.
[INAUDIBLE]
I can't remember what else.
It was four different
kinds of ways they
were tailored to the context.
And when I get this, this is
a notification on your phone.
And when I get
this notification,
I have three ways
to swipe it off.
I can press thumbs down.
It wasn't useful for me.
I can press thumbs
up, I liked it.
And it goes away then.
Or I can press this
button in the middle.
If I press the
button in the middle,
I turn off the intervention.
So if I know that I'm going
to be busy, for example,
I could turn off the
intervention for the next four
hours.
So I have control.
I, the user, have control.
This is nice.
AUDIENCE: How does it
find all that information
like the weather?
Does it pull it up [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN MURPHY: Right.
So we're using Google a lot,
as you could well imagine.
So we have-- so
I'm going to talk
about that in the next slide.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN MURPHY: No, no.
It's perfect.
So we're using the Google
activity recognition here.
For example-- and
you'll see why,
but we used the information
on the phone as to
whether or not you're
moving really fast.
You could be
driving, for example.
Whether or not you're
currently walking and so on.
And then we also
have the weather.
I'm not sure where
we pull that from,
because that's not specific
to that individual.
That's just specific
to that location.
And then we also look at
their Google Calendar,
actually, and classify
whether or not
the Google Calendar looks
busy or not, and so on.
And in the Jawbone, we get the
step count from the Jawbone.
I just want to talk to you
about the trial we ran,
because this was the study.
We wanted to design
it-- actually,
it turns out there were
all kinds of decision rules
we want to form.
There were other interventions
we were thinking about,
but I just focused on this
one activity recommendation
up to five times a day.
So we ran this study.
We've developed this study
called a micro randomized trial
to investigate whether or not
these activity recommendations
are working as designed.
So in these trials, what
happens is each participant
is randomized at
each decision time.
So in the case of Heart
Steps, it's a 42-day study.
There's five times a
day, so there's 210.
So each person is
randomized 210 times
over the course of the study.
And the smoking-- we're involved
in a smoking cessation study.
There it's every
minute, 10 hours a day,
10 days, so around
6,000 times or so.
So you can be
randomized a great deal.
Of course, most of
the time, you're
going to be
randomized to nothing.
So the thing I want to point out
these two points here before.
In the scientific
literature, these
might be-- these are akin to
full factorial trials, designs,
experimental designs.
And that sends a lot of
signals, and one signal it sends
is that you want to collect
data to develop a strategy,
a mobile health intervention.
You're not collecting data to
confirm that one mobile health
intervention is better, one
package is better than another.
Instead, you're trying to
develop a mobile health
intervention packet.
And it can also be viewed--
I think some of you
all will be familiar
with AB testing.
It's commonly used throughout
the advertising world
to decide where we're
going to place ads
on websites and so on.
And this generally is
between person randomization.
Every time someone
goes to the website,
the placements are
randomized, and we
have some contextual
information on them,
and we're trying to figure
out where to place an ad based
on that contextual information.
So it's an AB test.
And the single case
designs-- these
are used a lot in
the behavioral field,
and this is where generally,
most of the randomization
is with in-person randomization.
So what happens when you
get something versus what
happens when you don't get it?
And this is a combination.
It extends both of these.
It uses them in different ways
from the way they're normally
used, but the
design itself looks
similar to a combination
of these two.
So we're going to have
multiple people-- they'll
be randomized across
people and with in person.
And one other
thing I just wanted
to make a statement
about-- if you're
used to obtaining
large data sets,
this is clearer now,
particularly in the business
community, but for a
long time, a lot of us
thought, well, look.
Just give me tons of
data, tracking, say,
how people are accessing
an intervention,
and I'll use my algorithms
and tell you whether or not
the intervention is working.
And we now understand
better and better
that this is not the way you
want-- this is not the best
way to discover if an
intervention is working,
because the reasons why someone
accesses an intervention
may be strongly related to
how they behave following
receipt of that intervention.
And so you don't know if
the intervention caused
that behavior or
the reasons why they
accessed the intervention
are related to that behavior.
So randomization breaks
that so that we can just
see whether or not the
intervention causes
the behavior as [INAUDIBLE].
And that's why you see so
much randomization now,
both in the business community
as well as in the health field.
So in Heart Steps, we're
in this simplified aspect
of Heart Steps.
Heart Steps, we're only
looking to know whether or not
we should provide
a tailored activity
recommendation at these
five decision times per day,
42 days, 210.
And what we did was we
randomized 2/5, 3/5,
and you might ask why.
If you have had any
statistics in school,
you would know that we would
normally use 1/2 randomization.
It gives you highest power
to detect the signal.
The issue here is burden.
If you ping people too much
and suggest they do things,
they may start to
habituate and ignore you.
So we only want it on
average two suggestions
per day originally, so we
used five occasions, 2/5.
The first question
we wanted to ask
was, do these activity
suggestions have any impact?
And then we would
ask whether or not
the context affected the
impact of those suggestions.
So what we do is we
test for main effects.
So I'm concerned, because
it's 1:07 right now,
and how much time
do you think I have?
We started a little bit late,
but I think we should still--
MARK: We've got until
1:30 including Q&A.
SUSAN MURPHY: OK.
I just wanted to make sure.
Thanks.
So what we're going
to do here is--
so we're trying to figure
out how to design this study.
So when you say
design, we already
talked about we have
five decision points.
We're going to randomize
people to getting
their suggestion at each
of those decision points.
That seems all kind of clear.
The question is, how many
people do we have to recruit?
And that has cost
considerations when
you're trying to fund
a trial like this,
because it takes
time to, if you're
talking about human
subjects, it takes time
to recruit these people,
enroll them, and monitor.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to say, well,
how many subjects
do we need in order
to test whether or not
there's a signal at all
of these activities suggestions?
Does it have any impact on you?
So there's two
things that come up
that I think are
really cool here.
And these two considerations
make these types
of problems in mobile help
completely different from what
you see across the
health field when you're
talking about medications
or different kinds
of physical therapies and so on.
And here's the first,
and I'll talk to you
about the second after this.
So the first is that this is an
intervention that's occurring
in the context of your life.
It's right on your
hip that your phone
can ping you and intervene.
So there's this potential, as
I mentioned early, for burden.
It can be very burdensome.
And in particular, there's
a potential for habituation,
and habituation I'm using in
a very negative sense here.
That is when people habituate
to a message in a negative way,
they don't even see
it after awhile.
It's just not even there.
You and I are habituating
to all kinds of things.
It allows us to be productive.
We just don't even
see these issues.
You don't hear about the
noise outside and so on.
And so to the extent
people start to habituate,
we'll lose effect.
So we can't anticipate that
the effect early in the study
might be the same as the
effect later in the study,
because by then, they may have
habituated to these messages.
Now we do have
hundreds and hundreds
of messages we can
provide, and they
are tailored to the context.
But nonetheless, you
may still habituate.
And if you get aggravated, you
may just start ignoring them.
So what we're going to do is
when we talk about the signal
or what we call a
main effect-- that's
the signal, the effect
of the intervention
message on your
activity-- so what's
my activity look like if I
get a message versus what's
my activity look like if
I don't get a message?
We're going to allow
that to vary with time.
The other thing we
have to think about,
and this is also related.
This is very special
to mobile health--
is this issue of availability.
And this is something
only recently have we
in the research community
really began to appreciate.
And it's really important.
I think it's going to be a
dominant issue going forward.
And that is you cannot provide
an intervention to someone when
they're not available.
So for example, in Heart
Steps, if the Google classifier
indicated that you might
be driving the car,
we would not have
the phone light up,
ping, and possibly interrupt
you and prevent you
from paying attention
to the road.
We just wouldn't do that.
Also, if the Google
classifier that's on the phone
indicated that you're
currently walking,
we didn't want the phone to
ping-- audibly ping-- light up,
and suggest you go for walk.
That would just
be so aggravating.
So you're not
available at that time.
The other way you
might not be available
is if you don't
want to be bothered,
so you have turned
off the intervention.
You've said, don't bother me.
So for example, like
I had days where
I knew I was going
to go from one--
I was going to review
meetings all day.
I would turn off the
intervention for the whole day.
Those are times when
I'm not available.
So when we talk about the signal
or what I call the main effect,
and we say it's
time varying, it's
not only that it's
time varying because
of burden and habituation.
It also-- the signal
at time 30 is only
among the people who are
available at time 30.
So at each point in
time, the population
among whom I'm going to
ask if there's an effect,
is a different group of people.
It could be a slightly
different group of people.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So do you find, because you
can track when somebody is,
say, walking, that
if you were to give
a message of support, so
congrats, you're out walking,
whatever that [INAUDIBLE] that
you can reduce habituation
over the 42 days so that
at the end of the trial,
it's less variance versus
people who started.
Do you not measure [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN MURPHY: In Heart
Steps, we're not.
But right now, I told you
we were involved with an app
challenge, because we're very
interested in-- so there's
therapeutic interventions.
That's what we're
talking about today.
They're therapeutic,
because these
are people who are
sedentary, and we're trying
to prevent bad health outcomes.
There's also engagement
interventions,
and that's what
you're talking about.
How can I make them more
engaged with my intervention?
And we are working exactly
on those kinds of problems.
How do we feed back, give
them encouraging messages?
They're currently doing
something that's good for them.
How do we help them feel
good about this whole--
and we're working on that now.
And there's a lot of interest
in having both just in time
adaptive interventions that both
have engagement or reinforcers.
The interventions themselves
are reinforcers, as well as
therapeutic in some sense.
Yeah.
I mean this is a big-- and I
personally think that latter,
the reinforcers are going
to be even more important.
And if we can keep
you engaged long term,
we have the potential
to help you long term.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just
was just wondering
the impacts on habituation and
burden on future messaging.
SUSAN MURPHY: That's
the whole game.
That is the whole game.
So we haven't run a study where
we know what that impact is,
but we hope that
it would be good.
So we're designing
studies to test this.
AUDIENCE: Human studies or
human nature, you would think--
SUSAN MURPHY: You would think.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN MURPHY: You've
got to be careful.
Right.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So at this point,
there are a lot of apps
out there.
Like FitBit has their
own app, and they
use this engagement
model [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN MURPHY: Right.
AUDIENCE: Community sharing.
A lot of social--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN MURPHY: --competitions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you think about this, and
when this research is going,
how are you thinking about
it different from what's
already out there?
What's popular, what isn't
SUSAN MURPHY: Right.
AUDIENCE: So we've
got 20 wearables now.
They all tap into
an app [INAUDIBLE].
How do you they see all of
your studies to be different?
Do you even see
it as [INAUDIBLE]?
Where is it going
eventually [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN MURPHY: Oh,
I can tell you.
Yeah.
OK.
That's cool.
So there are a lot--
there are groups
that are very interested
in pushing the research
boundaries, not only having a
commercially viable product,
but also pushing
our understanding
of behavior science, the
boundaries of behavior science.
There are commercial
groups that are doing this.
I think Microsoft
has it in Health Arm.
Google DeepMind has
some interest in this.
So there is, but by and large,
mostly in the commercial world,
there is a-- you're looking
for a commercially viable app.
And that may just
mean that we need
people to engage for a month.
And then it's
commercially viable.
So in our world though,
in the world we're in,
we're both interested in
pushing the boundaries
of behavioral science, as well
as having a health impact.
So whatever-- we really want
to take apart these black boxes
and understand what
parts of the intervention
really work the way we
intended them to do.
And can we test the way our
understanding of behavior--
can we test it and
further develop it?
So habituation is a big
player in this game,
and in fact, as you
may already know,
most health apps that
you can download,
the attrition to health
apps is profound.
It's really bad.
It's like within two months, 75%
of people don't even use them.
It's a big problem.
But commercially
that may be fine.
It just depends on what your
commercial objective is.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess
my question was also
along the lines of
since that happens,
in the scope of your research,
how do you implement that?
And how can you get
some research points
to actually help people
continue with this [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN MURPHY: Right.
So that's why we look
at that micro-- that's
the whole purpose of these
micro randomized studies.
Is the intervention
working in the way
in which we designed it?
We designed it to have an
in-the-moment impact on you?
Did it?
Did the social networking
have an in-the-moment impact?
Did the gaming,
like often there's
interventions which have
a game-like structure.
Some people at some
times, that may not work.
We want to really
understand that.
And I'm not saying I
actually am working
with a number of
startups, and they
want to answer those
questions as well.
But we do too.
And we want to help
the behavioral theory,
develop behavioral theory
so that we can come up
and think of even more
innovative interventions,
both engagement as well
as therapeutic, actually.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Susan.
I have a question for you.
What's your vision that really
motivates you to do this?
SUSAN MURPHY: Yeah.
This is a good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
stop smoking.
Or what was the--
SUSAN MURPHY: No.
My vision-- no.
I'm a data scientist, OK?
Let's be honest about
what my vision is.
My vision is what
we're going to do
is we're going to use-- I'm
going to really get off track
here.
Just please forgive me,
all those guys on the-- so
we're going to use these
micro randomized trials.
We tested that there's a signal.
Then what we'll do is
we're developing methods
to develop what we call warm
start just in time adaptive
interventions.
That is these are
adaptive interventions
that we use that data to try and
get those decision rules pinned
down.
Then in our last study, for
example, in Heart Steps,
and in our last study,
we'll start everyone off
on the warm start.
And then we're going to have
algorithms that run locally
on the phone, so they
have to be computationally
efficient, less so as time goes
on, but you know what I mean.
But anyway, they will
personalize those decision
rules to each one of us.
And we want to personalize the--
so this is a field of health.
We have to be really careful.
This is very different
from personalizing ads.
We don't want to have any--
we want to really avoid
iatrogenic effects.
We don't want to
disillusion you if you're
trying-- say you're
someone who's trying
to control your binge eating.
We don't want you to
become disillusioned.
I mean we really have to worry
about-- in our experimentation,
we have to be concerned
about having bad effects.
So when we develop
these algorithms that
will personalize the
intervention to you,
we have to also monitor
them the whole time.
So let me just make it
a little bit more clear.
Remember in the example
of that decision rule,
I said that there was this
threshold for how long
you've been working
on the computer,
and that threshold may
differ from person to person.
Mine may be 30 minutes.
Mark's may be an hour,
and it may differ
on what my calendar looks like.
It may differ by
all kinds of things
that are going on in my life.
So that threshold, we can start
at the beginning of the study.
It would be something
pretty simple.
Mark's male.
I'm female.
Maybe we have different
thresholds, because one's male,
one's female.
He works in one kind of job.
I work in a totally
different job.
Maybe we have different
thresholds for that reason.
But then if you get two
people like me, both female.
We both have the
same sort of job.
There may be a way-- as
watching me through time,
we may learn that I respond
to that intervention,
those suggestions to get
up and move differently
than the other person.
And that's what the
algorithms will do.
And that's my long term goal is
to have really cool algorithms
that do that.
So of course, I want
to help my colleagues.
I'm part of big teams with
behavioral scientists, computer
scientists, and I want them to
advance their science as well.
And to the extent that
they advance their science,
and I advance my science, and
that we can work with the--
we have startups that
we're working with.
To the extent that we can
help them be more effective,
everything gets better.
I can advance my science too.
Yeah.
So that's the long term goal.
Now I got way off track.
[LAUGHS] That's fine.
So I just want to--
I think I'm just
going to show you this picture.
I just want to harp on that
little availability issue
a little bit more, because it's
something that we just really
didn't understand in mobile
health until recently.
So like here, I've just drawn in
a very cartoonish fashion what
the effect of having a
suggestion versus not having
a suggestion might look like.
So I have 210 decision
points in Heart Steps.
This is the difference between--
it's a standardized difference,
so it's a signal to noise ratio
in terms of your activity,
getting a suggestion versus not.
So you can imagine
people may come in.
So this is highly
simplistic, like I said,
because you can
imagine it probably
varies by day of the
week, time of the day,
and so on-- weather.
But anyhow, at the
beginning, there's
not much going on,
because you just started
getting these suggestions.
You don't know how
to make use of them.
You don't even
notice them at first.
Then you start trying them
out when you get them.
You don't try anything
out when you don't, so you
see an effect increase.
Then habituation comes in.
I get tired of them, and
I stop paying attention.
And so you don't see any
effect of a message on me.
That's one reason
why you might see
this kind of
curvilinear relationship
with the decreasing effect.
Another reason, though,
you might see a changing
signal over time,
and we really need
to understand that and somehow
bring that into the theory,
is that the group of people who
are available to be intervened
on varies with time.
So there's going to be one
group of people that have
really drank this Kool-Aid.
They've started walking
most of those times
or moving at those five
times, because they really
want to get with the game.
They're not going
to be available.
We're not going to be looking
at the effect of those people
as time goes on.
So it could be that the
people are still available,
or somehow they're
not as receptive,
or the suggestions just don't
have the same meaning for them.
So you might get a
decrease, because you
have a different population
on which you're looking.
Very interesting, and the
way in which you do science
when your population is
changing over time is different.
It's not something we've
done before in most
areas of experimentation.
Across all areas
of experimentation,
we don't normally have this.
It's an area that just comes up
mainly in mobile and wearables.
OK.
I just want to show
you some sample sizes,
and this, if you
know about-- these
are combinations of AB studies
and single case studies.
And the minute
you know that, you
know that when you
decide, when you try
and assess whether or not
you have a treatment effect,
you're going to compare both.
Mark and I are in the study.
He got a message.
I didn't.
You will compare whether or
not he was more active than me.
Between person comparison--
that's the AB part.
Also though, as I go
through this study,
you'll see me sometimes get
a message, sometimes don't.
Same for Mark.
And you'll compare me both
sometimes when I get it
and sometimes when
I don't, so that's
a within person contrast.
And so the minute you have
both between and within person
contrast, that
means you don't need
as big a number of
participants in your study,
and you can run studies
in a much more cost
efficient manner.
So I'm going to show you
some sample sizes here.
So this is a classical
way that we size trials.
We say with 80% power, I
want to detect whether or not
there's a signal.
I want to get
enough participants
so that with 80% power, I can
detect if there's a signal.
However, I'll tolerate
making an error
and saying that there's
a signal 5% of the time.
That's the traditional
way you design studies.
So this is traditional.
Then you also-- because
we're in this whole setting
of availability, we have to
anticipate whether or not
people-- what fraction of
the time do you think people
are going to be available?
70% of the time, 50% the time?
A good bit of the
time, they may not
be available for
our intervention.
And then there's the
signal to noise ratio
that you want to detect.
So in terms of the standard
deviation of step count,
what kind of-- do
I want to detect
0.5 movement in
standard deviations
or 0.1 movement in standard
deviations in step count?
So that's what
this is over here.
And what you see is if you have
a pretty high availability,
and you have a standardized
of you want to detect even
a 0.1 standard deviation
change in activity,
if you get a message
versus if you don't, you
don't need that
many participants.
Only 33 participants.
And this is really interesting.
First of all, these are very
small standardized effect size,
and it could be that we need
to even look at smaller ones.
But they accumulate
over time to the extent
we can prevent habituation when
we use reinforcers like you
were talking about earlier.
They would accumulate
over time, so we
can hope to magnify our effect.
So it's cool.
I just want to mention
that when people-- so we're
involved in a number of
studies where people want
to run whole series of
micro randomized studies,
then to get to that
warm start, and then
do the online personalisation.
You have to be
really careful when
you do design these studies.
You have to underestimate
availability.
So for example, if
you think people
are going to be available
70% of the time,
but they're only
available 50% of the time,
that's not good for you.
You need to underestimate.
A lot of data.
This type of data can be
used to form decision rules.
It's nice.
You can use it to
get your warm starts.
I think I'll just go-- this
is some members of our team.
I just want to indicate the
interdisciplinary nature
of these kinds of teams.
I think this would be-- you
would be accustomed to this,
because you have a very
interdisciplinary group.
We have behavioral
scientists here.
You have computer scientists.
We have guys who do human
computer interaction, how
you relate to the computer.
We have statisticians.
We have a sociologist.
We have another
behavioral scientist.
This guy works mainly
only in wearables.
So all of these
people come together
for you to run these
kinds of studies
and look for these signals.
That's it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]